[Music]
hello i'm amy lou wood and this is my
glamour unfiltered
[Music]
what i wish i'd learned from sex
education is that your body belongs to
you it doesn't belong to anybody else
and i think that's such a hard thing to
feel because when you look at yourself
you're seeing yourself through what
society wants and i think
just recently i've been really like god
this is just my body my body is mine and
it's for me
[Music]
i never really actually thought about
the contraception thing i just hadn't
ever questioned it it was just like you
get to a certain age and then you go on
a hormone you go on a pill or you get an
implant or something that stops you from
getting pregnant and it's your
responsibility why does the onus fall on
the woman when
a man could go and get
20 women pregnant more at once as women
we're expected to go through pain and
it's just
it's just kind of not even talked about
or even noticed it's just a given you're
you're in pain you're going to go
through pain your whole life and
men we have to make sure that they don't
have to and we need to avoid their pain
but yours is kind of you should be a
silent and kind of
modest and gracious suffering
[Music]
i think
season three handles
amy's kind of healing from her sexual
assault so beautifully it's still so
present for her and still because it's
huge and the fact that it's so
delicately
and
and kind of
beautifully portrayed throughout season
three i just thought it was such a
a kind of healthy and
wonderful thing to show that you know
you can ask for help you can go and get
help and
and
it had things are going to happen in
your life that are going to change you
but there are people here to support you
the fact that gene says to her no you
are never going to be the same you
aren't ever going to be the same and
it's this truth this truth that seems
harsh but actually it's the most freeing
thing she could say because what she's
saying is you aren't ever going to be
the same and that's fine and that's okay
you don't have to be or pretend to be
the same person you were before this
happened because unfortunately she no
longer really exists that person this
new
but in many ways this new bigger more
amazing version of you is present now um
and i think when amy says you know i
want to be strong like you and it jeans
kind of like you already are
[Music]
it's so
amazing watching people really
come into themselves and
acting getting better and better but
also as people
you know i think about how on the
how i would be spiraling after every day
on set i would be at home and i would be
in this spiral of i said this i did this
bit i shouldn't have done that bit like
that i shouldn't have done and it was
this self-doubt was huge and actually
this it was amazing doing season three
because i didn't even notice but i got a
few months into filming it and i just
was like my god you honestly just really
kind of do the scenes and if you want to
have another take you'll just say excuse
me can we have another one of that and
you do and then when you're happy you're
just happy and you kind of
you know
can let it go i can let things go a lot
more but that is also
a lot to do with sex education because
it it has been kind of like a second
drama school because it's been three
years
of being in a safe place where you can
make mistakes and you can mess up and
it's kind of like been the most amazing
acting
class because it's just so safe and
we've all started it was kind of most of
our first big thing
and
there was just such an equal playing
field from the get-go between like cast
crew everyone hi i'm patricia allison
and this is our sex education glamour
unfiltered enjoy
[Music]
we've never seen a character like that
before she really knows herself she's
very
smart she's quick she's emotional but
and she wears her heart on her sleeve
but you would never really you'd never
know that you know there's a lot going
on for her i'm just proud to play honor
i'm proud of proud of the show i'm proud
of the writers um that they write such
beautiful things and i've always had
people come up to me in the street and
talk about the show not necessarily
about me but other characters that
they've just been like this person and
this storyline really changed my life so
to be part of the show that is actually
changing people's lives and mindsets and
dialogue is very exciting and i'm proud
of that
[Music]
i think being mixed race as well has had
a huge
impact on my growing up and feeling
in the middle of things and feeling
a bit other it's nice to be able to be
in a show that champions
personalities or like characters that
aren't what we have typically seen you
know previously in tv shows and in
movies as to like what we aim beauty
standard wise you know and what we aim
to be like personality wise like it's
just it's nice to be
playing characters that are real okay so
they might have like you know fit into
like stereotypes in a way
but that's because we try and cover lots
of different types of people i guess in
that sense would try and make sure that
everyone's seen i just think it's nice
that we get to see
different characters because this world
is the genetic makeup of this world is
so
[ __ ] different and like there's just
so many of us that are all different
that make
one huge amazing population if we work
together
[Music]
i feel like the the sex scenes have
empowered me in my body image in a way
that as an actor i'm able to go on to
set now and say you know like i've
worked with an intimacy coordinator i
know what it feels like for me to be
comfortable in my body and for another
actor to be comfortable with me in a
space how do i approach the other actor
how do i talk to them like where do they
want to be touched you know what do they
want to do so just generally moving
forward with my own you know just being
confident in a space with somebody like
i feel like i have more respect because
i've got a dialogue and
a way to communicate with other people
and that's been amazing so early on in
my career because i know lots of
actresses who are much older and maybe
you've had to do sex scenes and it
wasn't as safe
previously and that can have a real
effect on your mental health as you get
on but i feel like we're we've been
quite protected and the fact that it's
not a gratuitous show in terms of sex
and and really clumsy and like messy and
painful sometimes it's very real because
we've all been through that experience
it's like literally all 100
been there didn't know what to say
having an awful awful time and not
finding the way to like communicate
about it afterwards and it just being
like a traumatic memory
and i think we need to change that and
move forward and sort of try and make it
more
open and you know and then i guess
get rid of the trauma and shame hi my
name is chelenya esidu and this is my
glamour unfiltered
[Music]
viv has taught me about myself
that i'm
becoming more confident as she becomes
more confident and she's finding herself
not just through her studies through the
people that she surrounds she's really
finding her tribe
um and that's such a nice thing to see
blossom on screen this series for viv
she just struggles with morality shame
and all of the things that young people
struggle with she's taught me to be
brave
mostly and i'm trying to do that in my
personal life as well
i think i was so unsure of myself when i
was young i didn't really know what i
was supposed to look like how my body
was supposed to look like
um
and now i'm just like just being myself
my complete authentic self
i think my yeah my my journey has
definitely evolved i feel
that we should all just
strive to be who we are and the best of
who we are and champion different types
of bodies champion different types of
skin tones everything i think self-worth
is so individual and it's so about self
so you have to really look into yourself
to
to be happy
[Music]
i think i've always felt like i was
othered i wasn't particularly academic i
didn't really fit into any categories i
really had to
to run my own race um
and i think that just came with time and
just trying to figure out who i wanted
to become
and not what people were pushing me to
become
[Music]
i feel that healthcare has always been a
bit biased towards people of color which
is not a great thing because we deserve
the best healthcare and in terms of
sex
um i think we should all be taught more
about it and find out what our bodies
like what our bodies don't like
[Music]
i feel
especially like with the blm movement um
it's been really a sobering moment for
everyone and we're all just trying to
come together universally everyone and
say this isn't right this this isn't how
we should be treated or how we want to
be treated so i feel everyone right now
is using their voice to impact
positively i feel we're all doing
something special right now with our
voices
[Music]
the first time
that i was introduced to everyone i was
really nervous
because they i came in in season two and
they obviously had their own like little
thing but everyone just welcomed me with
open arms and that just made me made me
feel really safe on set and i could just
do my best work
[Music]
i would say
just be bold just make random choices
um
and you're in the best company with the
most amazing people around you you are
safe
you are home
you are welcomed
[Music]